[Music]
[Music]
there are at least
13 000 worlds under the influence of the
great houses of the landsrad
at the start of the dune series holtzman
drive technology
allows for instantaneous travel between
the inhabited planets of the galaxy
after the reign of the god emperor the
great scattering of mankind
would send humans out in all directions
into the untraceable reaches of space
fifteen centuries passed before anyone
would return
out of the scattering into the former
ortradis empire
over the five thousand years of the
original dune saga
human beings continued to diversify some
groups isolated themselves to the point
where they were almost inhuman but not
quite
but even with humankind's exploration of
deep space
there appears to be no concrete evidence
of intelligent
alien life the dune encyclopedia
mentions the legend of the star
searcher this was during the time before
the guild
the legend was spoken of on many worlds
including arrakis
ix getty prime and ekkus
the legend speaks of the star searcher a
class
3 starship that continued to take on
grander proportions
until becoming a class 9 starship
according to the legend
in the year 480 bg the crew set off on a
long journey
towards the noosh star system partway
through their journey
they came across an abandoned cargo
vessel floating in space
upon returning from examining the empty
ship they resumed their journey
two weeks later the entire crew was
stricken by what must have been
an anti-cytologic microspore
the manifestations were high fever
sweating
dizziness and dementia magnum in a word
the crew went mad they experienced the
rarest form of psychosis
group paranoia in a matter of three
weeks they became convinced
that all civilization had been destroyed
by an invasion force
of hideous aliens who attacked with
unstoppable weapons
from invisible starships they radioed
this information to all receivers
using the widest spectrum of emergency
bans
the crew supposedly went insane they had
been fully convinced
that they and the rest of humanity were
under attack by an unseen
enemy the crew made the decision to fly
into space
in search of these unseen alien
attackers
until they eventually ran out of stores
the amperolis was never found
it is said to still be searching the
stars ever ready to attack the time
dilation effect of near light speed
travel
making the crew almost immortal
the people of the dune universe seem to
have at least considered the idea of
alien life
according to the great convention the
universal truce of mankind
held in place by the alliance of the
royal house the guild and the landsrad
the use of atomic weapons is preserved
for only non-human threats
the use of atomics against humans was
grounds for immediate planetary
obliteration
so it seems that the threat of alien
conflict
was at least somewhat thought of the
dune encyclopedia also mentions that
sometime
after the death of the god emperor the
crumpton ruins were discovered
the guild ship the rondelai captained by
levis crumpton
explored on the farthest borders of
inhabited space
they were investigating a g-type star
called sutter
4041 and its surrounding planets
the fourth planet which would eventually
be named crumpton
was within the star's ecosphere upon
investigating
they discovered that the world was
indeed habitable
after days of probing the world they
discovered
something which appeared to be an
artificial structure
almost a kilometer across the structure
was placed
on the central continent of the world at
the shore of its largest lake
acting under long-standing regulations
governing possible alien contact
the captain ryola sincheck directed the
satellite to closer and continuous
reconnaissance while she ordered the
ground crews to return to the ship
the new photos revealed that the
structure was considerably damaged
with no sign of activity of any kind in
the area
the ground team was eventually sent to
investigate the structure but found no
signs of intelligent life anywhere on
the surface of the world
the guild was fully convinced that no
human being had ever set
foot on the planet they who held a
monopoly on space travel were in the
position to know
and their records held no evidence that
the world had ever been visited by
humankind
news would eventually get out of this
discovery and the guild was determined
to know the origins of these strange
ruins
the second visit to the world was of an
enormous scale compared to the first
the second expedition of 14702
consisting of five highliners carrying a
host of personnel
and a mass of equipment returned to
crumpton
while the news of alien contact spread
through the inhabited worlds
teams of archaeologists architects
xenobiologists
and the like combed every centimeter of
the structure
and performed the most intensive survey
of an uninhabited planet ever undertaken
they discovered that the ruins were
between three thousand and five thousand
years old
further investigation of the solar
system yielded no clues as to where
these mysterious structures originated
the consensus was in fact that
intelligent alien life had been
responsible
for the crumpton ruins the ruins were
considered solid
evidence of the existence of intelligent
non-human life forms and it was not hard
to maintain this belief
the universe is a vast region and some
argue that it was not unlikely
that chan's occurrence put humanity on
the scene
some thousands of years after the aliens
had been on crumpton
still they argued while we might not
encounter the aliens tomorrow
or next year or even in the next hundred
years
we know from the ruins that they are out
there
and we need to think about what to do
when contact
does take place this belief however
crumbles once later the seconds
no room was later discovered on the
planet rakis
it turned out that the structure on
crumpton was basically identical to
later the second's no room
though it had been decomposed by
microorganisms on the world
that had the ability to easily break
down metals and vegetable in animal
fibers
the accepted theory of the crumpton
ruins being of alien origin
was all but demolished though the
specialists on the ruins
made the argument that nothing had truly
been solved by the discovery on raqqas
the nature of the problem before them
had simply shifted
instead of the question being about the
details of
alien habitation of crumpton the
question became about the mystery of how
and when
the god emperor had sent a construction
crew to the world
and why he had the structure built in
the first place
in many science fiction space epics
aliens play at least some role either
on the outskirts or out in they are as
much a part of galactic society as
humans are
alien life forms are often used as
metaphors in science fiction
for different groups of people or as
representatives of
the unknown or the other in doom the
roles that alien life forms tend to play
in most science fiction
are taken up by other humans the chile
laksu for example
are almost not human they have isolated
themselves on the planet flalax for
thousands of years they do not breed
with outsiders
and have developed the appearance of
small elf-like beings
the navigators of the guild also humans
but
they have been evolved in a process that
involves huge amounts of spice
melange however no matter their
appearance they are not alien
frank herbert wanted to tell the story
that was entirely human
he wanted to show us what we could
become he wanted to show us our
potential future
and some of the many different
directions that our human evolution
could take
even still there is at least one alien
being
in the doom series the planet arrakis
did not always have
the nickname dune eons ago arrakis was a
wet
planet a world of rivers oceans clouds
and trees
it wasn't until the sand trout were
brought to the world that this changed
you could never say that the sand worms
of arrakis were intelligent beings
certainly not before later the second's
consciousness was split
amongst them and yet so much of the
human universe centers around the worms
the entire economic structure of the
galaxy is centered around one of the
byproducts of its life cycle
the spice melange his voice
barely above a whisper he said i know
what happened ganima
she bent close to him yes the sand
drought
he fell silent and she wondered why he
kept referring to the haploid phase of
the planet's giant sand worm
but she dared not brought him the sand
trout
he repeated was introduced here from
some other place this was a wet planet
then
they proliferated beyond the capability
of existing ecosystems to deal with them
santrout insisted the available free
water
made this a desert planet and they did
it to survive
in a planet sufficiently dry they could
move to their
sand worm face the sand trout
she shook her head not doubting him but
unwilling to search those
depths where he gathered such
information and she thought
sand trout many times in this flesh
and others had she played the childhood
game
polling for sand trout teasing them into
a thin glove membrane before taking them
to the death still for their water it
was difficult to think
of this mindless little creature as a
shaper of enormous events
arrakis had not been special
somewhere out there in space there had
been
another dune perhaps it still existed
whether or not the worms had been
brought to arrakis by accident
or on purpose is unknown what is known
is that the indefinite survival of the
species is ensured
they intertwined themselves in the
fabric of human affairs
the precious spice was the most valued
commodity in the empire
many in the empire were addicted to the
substance and would die without it
flalaxus spice though usable was
believed by the bini jesuit to be
inferior to true spice
the worms had formed a kind of symbiotic
relationship with humans
intelligence is not the end all be all
of evolution
survival is the only goal the worm's
ability to produce substances
that affect the human consciousness and
physiology on such a level
has granted them an enormous
evolutionary advantage
it is not clear whether or not frank
herbert ever intended to introduce
intelligent alien life into the dune
series
if he was going there there are many
ways he could have done it
the story of the star searcher's
discovery of a derelict ship
for instance invokes some really great
cosmic terror concepts
which are common in the work of
lovecraft as a horror fan i personally
think this would have been
an interesting and pretty terrifying way
to introduce alien life into the dunes
series
thank you guys so much for watching my
video if you enjoyed this video make
sure you like and subscribe for more
quinn's ideas
and also if you would like follow me on
twitter and you can also support this
channel by clicking the patreon link
or making a one-time donation through
paypal also link in the description
peace